right ladies and gentlemen welcome to
this readout of the college meeting
which will be immediately followed by
statements from vice president Baum
Huskies commissioners gentiloni and
Schmitt on the European semester after
which we'll be happy to take your
questions on issues that were raised in
college or on the European semester
itself good afternoon everybody
so today together with commissioners
gentiloni and Schmidt we presented a
package launching a new cycle of
European semester exercise so I will
come back to this in a minute following
is a college readout so on other items
in college agenda today vice president
suits introduced orientation debate on
the conference on the future of Europe
on which preparation will follow two
parallel strands one strand focusing on
internal inter-institutional debates
with a commission acting as an honest
broker between the European Parliament
and the council and as the second strand
looking at securing broader outreach and
aiming to establish debate with citizen
structure around six commission
priorities and the council strategic
agenda then the head of the task force
for relations with the United Kingdom
Michel Barnier
updated the College on the next steps as
regards withdrawal of the UK from the
Union following UK in general elections
of twelve of December and the European
Council meeting of 13th of December
a coach also took note on the agreement
between the European Parliament and the
Council on the mobility package
following last week's trial log and
Commission issued a declaration
regretting is that a political agreement
reached by the council and Parliament
includes elements that are not in line
with ambitions of the European Green
Deal
zere's these are as a compulsory return
of the vehicle to the member state of
establishment every eight weeks and
restrictions imposed on combined
transport operations these measures were
not part of the original Commission's
proposal were not subject to the impact
assessment the obligation of return of
the track will lead to inefficiencies in
the transport system and increase if
unnecessary emissions pollution and
congestion while the restriction on
combined transport diminish its
effectiveness to support multimodal
freight operations so the Commission
will now closely assess the climate
environmental and single market
functioning impact of those two aspects
and after impact assessment as a
commission if necessary will exercise
its right to come forward with a
targeted legislative proposal before the
two provisions enter into force then
moving back to the European semester
today's package sets out our economic
policy priorities for the coming year so
before presenting the main features of
our annual sustainable growth strategy
allow me give some context European
economy is now in the seventh year of
consecutive growth employment is at a
record high seventeen point four million
jobs have been created in a new since
the start of 2013
public finances have improved with
aggregate deficit of 0.7% of GDP in 2018
down from two and a half percent of GDP
in 2014 and debt to GDP ratio in the
euro area fall from a peak of 2013 94
5.2 percent in 2014 to 80 7.9 percent in
2018 no member state currently has an
excessive deficit result Romanian
developments in Romania suggested this
may not lost we must remain competitive
and do so in a way that is sustainable
and fair our economy must work for the
people and for the planet our economic
strategy must be fully in step with a
European Green Deal that the Commission
presented last week and at the same time
we cannot ignore global uncertainty and
geopolitical risks as a horizon three
profound shifts will define decades to
come climate change technological
progress and digitization and
demographical change we must face these
challenges head-on and act decisively
and with the right performance four
guiding principles will underpin our
strategy stability fairness productivity
and sustainability let me begin with
economic stability which is precondition
for economic growth and transformation
fiscal policies need to be responsible
and appropriately differentiated leading
to sound and sustainable public finances
in line with the commonly agreed rules
differentiate fiscal policies means that
countries which shall fiscal space are
invited to continue using it now but
those whose high debt levels should
bring it down depth matters bringing
depth down builds confidence in the
economy and makes countries more
shockproof it drives down borrowing
costs which means there is
more funding for public investment
speaking of EU fiscal rules in January
will present the review of six pack and
2-pack legislation to see how the rules
have worked
I predict a lively debate around EU
fiscal rules so we have to exercise
caution we will need to see whether a
consensus emerges from that debate a
word of on European monetary economic
and monetary union and our single
currency the latest Eurobarometer survey
shows the highest support for the euro
since its introduction in 2002 76% of
correspondent sings a single currency is
good for the EU and the risk I support
for greater coordination on policy we
now need to complete our economic and
monetary union to ensure that we have
all the economic tools we need to face
storms on the horizon the euro is a
symbol of Europe's unity and global
strengths stronger EMU will help to pre
enforce the international role of the
euro and increase European cloud on
global markets second principle we need
to focus on making economies to make our
economies more productive by embracing
technology and digitalization we need to
change outdated economic structure so we
can become a global leader in an
increasingly digitalized world and
harness great creative potential what
Europe has so you know ITU countries to
step up their reform efforts and Paulo
will go into more detail regarding the
security situation of macroeconomic
imbalances the third pillar is
sustainability climate change is a
biggest challenge we face today the
transition to climate neutrality will
require major investment with a strong
focus on environmental sustainability
the European semester is reinforced as
an encompassing tool for economic and
social policy making
Paulo will tell you more about
integrating sustainable development
goals in the European semester we are
also working together on a sustainable
Europe investment plan which will
provide dedicated financing for
sustainable investments in every part of
the EU but none of this can happen
without Europe having a shared
understanding of what green economic
activity is so I welcomes a breakthrough
between EU colleges laters last night on
vital legislation to create a green list
or taxonomy of sustainable economic
activities this piece of legislation is
crucial for the Green Deal to become a
reality it will enable green investments
to flow for each scale and here help
Europe reach climate neutrality by 2050
the European Parliament and Member
States should now formally endorse this
agreement as a commission stands ready
to work swiftly on getting the first
lists of climate mitigation and
adaptation activities as soon as
possible the fourth principle in our
economic strategy is fairness be degree
no digital we need to put people at the
heart of the transitions so no person
and no region should be left behind
there is a big upside because if managed
well the green and digital transitions
can create many jobs and a healthier
working and living environment these
transitions can actually help to deliver
on the social pillar and put Europe as a
competitive advantage in comparison to
other regions in the world
Nicola will tell you more on this one
last word on our single market report
which is a novelty the single market has
a crucial role to play in our growth
strategy so this report assesses its
performance and areas were more progress
is necessary such as services and public
procurement thank you and now I give you
a word to say paolo gentiloni
please thank you